dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here in an
earlier work we were able to change a
photo of an already existing design
according to our taste that was
absolutely amazing
but now hold on to your papers and have
a look at this because here we can
create something out of thin air the
input in this problem formulation is an
image and the output is an image of a
different kind
let's call this process image
translation it is translation in a sense
that for instance we can add an aerial
view of a city as an input and get a map
of this city as an output or we can draw
the silhouette of a handbag and have it
translated to an actual real looking
object and we can go even crazier
for instance day to night conversion of
the photograph is also possible
what an incredible idea and look at the
quality of the execution ice cream for
my eyes and as always please don't think
of this algorithm at the end of the road
like all papers this is a stepping stone
and a few more words down the line the
kinks will be fixed and the output
quality is going to be vastly improved
the technique uses a conditional
adversarial network to accomplish this
this works the following way there is a
generative neural network that creates
new images all day and the discriminator
network is also available all day to
judge whether these images look natural
or not during this process the generator
network learns to draw more realistic
images and the discriminator network
learns to tell fake images from real
ones if they train together for long
enough they will be able to reliably
create these image translations for a
large set of different scenarios there
are two key differences that make this
piece of work stand out from the
classical generative adversarial
networks one both neural networks have
the opportunity to look at the
before-and-after images
normally we restrict a problem to only
looking at the after images the final
results and two instead of only positive
both positive and not
examples are generated this means that
the generator network is also asked to
create really bad images on purpose so
that the discriminator network can more
reliably learn the distinction between
flippant attempt and quality
craftsmanship another great selling
point here is that we don't need several
different algorithms for each of the
cases the same generic approach is used
for all the maps and photographs the
only thing that is different is the
training data twitter has blown up with
fun experiments most of them include
cute drawings ending up as horrifying
looking cats and the title of the video
says the results are always going to be
stunning but sometimes a different kind
of stunning than we'd expect it's so
delightful to see that people are having
a great time with this technique and it
is always a great choice to put out such
a work for a wide audience to play with
and if you get excited for this project
there are tons and I mean tons of links
in the video description including one -
the source code of the project so make
sure to have a look and read up some
more on the topic there's going to be
lots of fun to be here you can also try
it for yourself
there is a link to an online demo in the
description and if you post your results
in the comment section I guarantee there
will be some amusing discussions I feel
that soon a new era of video games and
movies will dawn when most of the
digital models are drawn by computers
and automation and mass producing is a
standard in many industries nowadays
will surely be hearing people going do
you remember the good old times when
video games were handcrafted man those
were the days if you enjoyed this
episode make sure to subscribe to the
series we try our best to put out 2 of
these videos per week we would be happy
to have you join our growing club of
fellow scholars and be a part of our
journey to the world of incredible
research works such as this one thanks
for watching and for your generous
support I'll see you next time
[Music]
Oh